you're dark I was thinking tonight could
be a good night for sex night possibly
interesting idea but you
know Thursdays
Stephen London how's the new Opera
coming along good great great we had
discussed seeing a first draft of the
score in two weeks is it still all right
I'm suffering from a temporary blockage
at the moment
no turn it back on
come on
one two five
is he all right he had a total breakout
after his last opera
can't do this
we need to take a walk jolt your brain
out of its little rad pattern interact
with a stranger okay honey I have a
patient bye
are we going that way I keep imagining
you naked I don't know if you want to
hear more details about these images no
[Music]
about every one of these people has a
story for an opera in them Levi
I operate a Tempo the wrong hands this
tug is a deadly weapon
isn't everybody
rested for stalking I
think and I'm not supposed to be doing
this
can't believe that actually happened I
mean she seduced me right she's a witch
the demented tugboat captain who knows
men to her Tugboat and kills them
beneath them I've loved it how did you
come up with that
that was really angry at you and now it
turns out on your amused do what oh see
I'll never leave you
um
I love cleaning cleanliness is close to
Godliness where my patients are talking
I imagine getting inside their heads
with disinfectant and just scrubbing
them down
your tugboat captain came to see me I'm
in Love no no just admit that I had a
magic effect on you my imagination came
up with the story my talent wrote the
music I mean you don't kill men and eat
them do you no I haven't yet
no I can't resist a romantic story even
if I'm not in it
[Music]